Kate Middleton had a special guest on
her latest royal outing her
brother-in-law and soon-to-be first-time
dad Prince Harry that's right Harry made
a surprise appearance on Thursday
stepping out with the Duchess of
Cambridge to honor fallen Australian and
New Zealand veterans during the annual
Anzac Day service of commemoration and
Thanksgiving at Westminster Abbey
despite the solemn occasion the pair
were all smiles as they headed inside
Kate in a blue feathered hat matching
coat and green heels Harry in a navy
suit with a red and navy striped tie
both wore red poppy pins a symbol used
since 1921
to commemorate military members who have
died in war the in-law outing comes amid
rumors of tension between Prince William
and Prince Harry the palace have tried
to knock these rumours of attention
between the four Royals on the head and
it does seem to be the case that perhaps
they they don't all get along
as well as we thought that they might do
I think people forget these are still
early days and I think it's a matter of
all of them trying to find their feet as
a foursome for so long we had the royal
trio and you know Harry William and Kate
now of course we've got Megan
but things appear to be a-ok based off
Thursday's appearance and it's no
surprise Harry was grinning ear-to-ear a
royal source tells ET his wife Megan
Merkel is due to give birth to their
first child together quote any day now
they're super excited about the spring
birth of their baby and I'm told that
she's upbeat and that she's happy
Megan's mom Doria Ragland arrived in
London over the weekend in anticipation
of the royal baby's arrival a source
recently told ET megan is enjoying her
pregnancy adding quote it is such a
happy and exciting time for Megan she is
looking forward to becoming a mother
[Music]